on a very cold very dark Monday night in
East Malti in Surrey hundreds of people
gather for the event of the week a
general election hustings and in this
the constituency of one Dominic Roth the
land of long shadows on cricket pitches
and the equal privet edges of deep
gentle England they're not happy
[Music]
[Applause]
within the name of your party and then
cut so the biggest Democratic mandate
[Applause]
this is true-blue invincible toy suburb
country yet something old is happening
in places like this barrettes it has
politicized people who before had looked
to be political about that wasn't very
gentle I was ashamed of it sometimes I
yes I was Tory all my life but no more
here no always always and there are a
lot of people in this constituency who
have been Tory voters but they don't
want mr. rabe anymore party of Ken Clark
and Nikolas Soames michael has no time
for goodness sake you know it's not the
same Tory party and that's what makes
seats across the South interesting the
Lib Dems might be sinking in the
national polls but look beneath the
surface in the Home Counties places like
sorry and Hampshire they are hopeful of
some major upsets with lifelong Tories
coming their way I'm voting for you in a
big big decision right because I'm
nearly always voted conservatives before
do you think there are a lot of people
like you around here conservative number
yeah you voted conservative 17 I did
so what's change between now and then
because obviously the potholes the
breakfast that the mayhem that's gone on
with the Tories I normally vote
conservative but I can't bear the poor
food oh really
I call him a buffoon and anybody who
doesn't know he needs longer shirts is
an idiot there's plenty of Tory support
here still but as the party is shifted
whenever pure brexit hugh courting lay
believers in the north it has produced a
counter-reaction across the south
I don't think they picked up quite how
annoying people are with the
Conservatives here I think now in the
South of England and I can own Home
Counties I think there is a really
strong movement of conservatives that
want to send a message to the party
that's not the way it was even if brexit
gets done the shifts in voter base is
being
right now could endure for elections to
come brexit and Boris Johnson are
opening up new territory for the Tories
but at what cost Lewis Caroll's can use
in Surrey and Hampshire